okay well let's take you back to
minneapolis that breaking news coming to
us
from the united states that the jury
in the derek chauvin trial for the
killing of george floyd
has reached a verdict and we should be
hearing that verdict
in the next 10 minutes or or so
the jury has returned you can see those
shots there of course
images of the many shocking videos that
we've seen of those nine minutes
and the half where derek chauvin kept
his knee
on uh george floyd's neck let me just
remind you
of the charges that derek chauvin is
facing now the first charge is
unintentional second degree murder with
a penalty of up to 40 years in prison
now for this prosecutors had to prove
that uh chauvin's conduct
was a substantial causal factor in
george floyd's death
and chauvin was actually committing
felony assault
at the time so that would be for
second-degree murder he's also charged
with
third degree murder that means that his
actions
actually caused floyd's death with
recklessness and disregard for human
life
and then the lesser charge was second
degree manslaughter which just required
proof
that chauvin caused george floyd's death
through
negligence so those are the three
charges and we do know that the jury
has reached a verdict well al jazeera's
john hendren is has been following the
trial
for the past three weeks for us in
minneapolis and it is outside
the courthouse uh now now the jury
didn't really deliberate for
that long considering the three-week
trial tell us a little bit about what
the atmosphere
is like outside the courthouse now
well there's been a sudden flurry of
activity we've seen
people heading toward the courthouse
ready for whatever that verdict is and
then we've seen vehicles
going the other direction trying to
leave town and avoid
the potential chaos that could ensue
we are told by the pool reporters inside
the courthouse
that derek chauvin and his lawyer eric
nelson are
inside of the building they're getting
ready for that verdict with in just
a matter of minutes and
there is a lot of speculation about the
speed with which the jury
came to a verdict i believe it was about
10 hours
some of it yesterday on monday some of
it today on tuesday
but generally lawyers tell me they
that tends to favor the prosecution but
it's not always the case the one message
that it really gives is that jury did
not have a really difficult time
deciding what the facts were
in this case you got three complicated
sets of charges there and as you just
ticked off each of them has a different
level of proof so you would expect it to
take some time
for the jury to try to go through those
and determine what the appropriate
charges were whether they were
set toward guilt or innocence
one of the lawyers i spoke to said he
would not be surprised to hear
a verdict of guilty on all counts
because of the speed with which this
came up now
we've been surprised before there was
the o.j simpson case where in four hours
that jury came back and said he was not
guilty with a unanimous verdict and of
course
that's what we have to remember here the
fact that the jury has come back means
all 12 of them
have agreed on a verdict whether that is
guilt or
innocence and there was always concern
that there might be a hung jury that you
might have a juror or two
who simply would not go along with the
rest of them well apparently that is not
what is happening here and you can see
this is
a stream of cars headed to the
courthouse behind me there
so we are all waiting and anxious and we
expect that
whatever happens is this will be a night
either of
disappointment or celebration
at any rate uh wanted to be prepared a
3 000 member of the minnesota national
guard alongside the police
employed to try to keep the city safe
there could be unrest after the
true and we we've seen a little hint of
that when we have
just days ago the police fatal shooting
of the right
in the nearby town of brooklyn center
that has generated
seven eight days of protests
there and that is only about 15
kilometers from here so really the
protesters that you see here are the
same ones
that have gone there and the city
learned the hard way
that sometimes you need to staff up the
numbers in order to be able to control
the crowds here
in the first days of the protests over
george floyd's death in may
those police were overwhelmed with
protesters
and there were angry incidents of
looting and rioting along with the
largely
peaceful protest that we saw in the
daytime but
it's not just limited to minneapolis
there are national guard troops in
washington d.c lingering from the
january 6th attack on the capitol and in
chicago
governor jb pritzker has called in 150
national guard troops there to
supplement
hundreds and hundreds of chicago police
and here in minneapolis
uh police leave has been canceled the
schools have been canceled
for the rest of the week so as you can
imagine
this city is gearing up for a response
to that the only question is what that
response
will be
and though john stay with us we can see
some live pictures
the other side of the courthouse from
where you're standing people obviously
uh gathering there
members of the media as well as certain
people with cameras but a lot of people
there have
gathered uh waiting for the verdict
which has been reached by
the jury john just remind us what were
the main arguments of
both the prosecution and the defense
well you outlined what those charges
were but the elements of those
charges the things that the prosecution
had to prove
were really very simple they were a did
derek chauvin
cause the death of george floyd the
prosecution says he absolutely did and
they used a number of witnesses largely
medical witnesses
to show that he put his knee on george
floyd's neck in a way
that according to prosecution witnesses
cut off his air pipe
and then that ended up ending his brain
function
and his heart which ultimately gave out
and that death
was ruled a homicide so they have some
support in the medical examiner's report
now the other thing they had to prove
was that
chauvin was not within his rights to be
using deadly force in that case and the
big argument there was that
about halfway or less through the nine
and a half minutes when he had his knee
on george floyd's neck
george floyd was no longer moving no
longer resisting well we saw a stream of
prosecution police
tactical witnesses who said that that
was inappropriate
and that included the chief of police so
if this is a guilty conviction
the two elements that they will have
proved
to the satisfaction of the jury are that
derek chauvin
killed george floyd and that he was not
within his rights
to use the force that he used one of the
things that we also heard
when you talk about negligence in that
manslaughter charge
one of the things we heard was that
medical witnesses and police witnesses
says
that a police officer in minneapolis is
obligated to render aid to someone who
is in their custody
if they are in medical distress and we
saw that derek chovin did
not do that and we saw at one point
another officer checks the pulse of
george floyd
and comes up with nothing still chauvin
did not
get up off of floyd until the paramedics
came
and carried his lifeless body away so
those are really the the elements of the
case
the defense argued that something else
killed
george floyd as improbable as that might
seem and they threw up the possibilities
of his
heart trouble he had clogged arteries
they brought
up drugs that were in his system
methamphetamine and fentanyl
and they also even brought up the
possibility that the car
exhaust contributed to his death the
idea
seemed to be that he would have died
that night anyway
well we'll see in a matter of minutes
whether that argument
flew with the jury we will indeed john
hendren for the moment
uh thank you let's cross to the other
side of the courthouse
and speak to al jazeera's shihab
brettansi uh who is there
uh where several protesters have
gathered uh what kind of things are they
saying
uh what is their reason for for being
outside the courthouse now
i mean we still are in that situation
where the protesters are
vastly outnumbered by the media but
there is no charge of black lives matter
underway in that in that crowd anyone
with a flag or anything is immediately
surrounded
by you know tens of press uh members of
the press with their cameras
uh but clearly i mean i'm just to repeat
what i was saying a bit earlier i mean
that that that sentiment of being
pessimistically optimistic that we heard
from a member of
of george floyd's family this morning
does seem to sum things up because as
jon hendren was saying
of the speed of the off the decision
but i think what's also about pessimism
isn't just about
the verdict it's about the reaction of
the security forces who've been drafted
in
from across the state and actually the
governor of minnesota has even
declared a domestic emergency so he can
now draw on the resources of ohio and
nebraska as well
in fact we were at this we were at this
spot this morning and there was a
protest again not
just about the killing of george floyd
the killer and the police brutality
but the manner in which the state has
has policed the outpouring of grief
and the and the outpouring of
collective resolution that things have
to change
because it you know it has been john was
mentioning it before we you know
even during this trial another 20 year
old black man was killed
by a police officer last last week and
that led to various protests in brooklyn
center about
16 kilometers north of where of where we
are and we saw it firsthand
the police the plans for policing the
aftermath of a derrick chauvin verdict
were effectively
brought up they were they were they were
immediately put into place
in this tiny little suburb 16 kilometers
north of us
so they descended upon by thousands of
troops national guards state troopers
and others
who proceeded to do what we often see
which is
allow protests up to a point but then at
sort of almost a kind of random point in
the evening they would suddenly start
firing
tear gas flashbangs rubber bullets even
as the mayor
and the city council voted that that
they should not be allowed to be used
against peaceful
peaceful protesters what we also saw was
them actively targeting the media we
were detained at one point as well
it was something i've never seen
actually in all my head all the years of
covering these sorts of protests
the governor has said that he's they'll
do better now that they won't
react in such a way but i think that's
the other main variable today
with this verdict is how will the
security forces
react to crowds you know the emotions of
the crowd no matter what
what the verdict is i wanted also to
bring up something else though
something we keep hearing and we had it
again this morning at the protest was
it was interesting when the lawyers at
the end of the chauvin trial said
um said look this isn't the entire
minneapolis police department on trial
this is derek chauvin on trial and i
think the activists here
i mean they may understand why the
prosecutors
framed it in that manner so that the and
we know that some members of the jury
were very pro police
but that isn't the point of the
protesters out here that constant point
is it's not a few bad apples this isn't
about a derek chauvin
or a kim potter who killed who who
killed dante wright last week
i mean just the mere fact that it
happened during the trial suggests
something else this is systemic
this is a problem with policing in
america not only is the minneapolis
police department on trial
all police departments in america are on
trial so that's a very interesting
message which actually differs from the
message
that we heard from the prosecutors
yesterday
this is about a fundamental problem with
policing in america
and indeed what was interesting also
this morning we heard you know joe biden
has now weighed in
and he said that he was praying for the
right verdict which i think is
overwhelming in my
view but what we kept hearing from
speaker after speaker this morning was
do something joe biden you're now in
power you have both houses of congress
you said you would be different to the
other to the other parties to the
republicans you haven't done anything
yet do something
get on a plane for a start get down here
and start talking to people we don't
need you to cry on the shoulder of
another black family who's lost
a family member one person said we
needed to actually do something
so this this idea of the biden's
empathetic presidency wasn't going down
terribly well here this morning because
they were saying well
yeah all right that's all very well but
do something
shia bratanzi with the latest uh with
several protesters who have gathered
outside the courthouse she
she have for the moment uh thank you and
just a reminder uh
for the viewers tuning in right now we
have heard
that the jury in the derek chauvin trial
for the killing of george floyd
have reached a verdict so we are
expecting them to appear in court
uh any time now really we were told
about uh
2030 gmt so anytime now we are expecting
the jury to go back to court and return
a verdict well let's just remind you now
what the three charges are that derek
chauvin actually faces
now the first is unintentional second
degree murder with a penalty of up to 40
years in prison
prosecutors had to prove that his
conduct was a substantial causal factor
in george floyd's death
and chauvin was committing felony
assault
at the time now he's also facing a third
degree murder charge
that means his actions caused floyd's
death with recklessness
and the disregard for human life and
then there's
second degree manslaughter which
requires proof that chauvin
caused floyd's death through negligence
so those
are the three charges let's go back to
debbie hines a former baltimore city
prosecutor
and the trial lawyer who joins us now
from
washington d.c just explain
the legal angles to this can he be found
guilty
of all three charges or could he be
found guilty i mean presumably can be
found guilty of the lesser ones
but if he's found guilty of the most
serious one does that mean he's
automatically guilty of the other two as
well
now so the judge instructed the jury and
let me just
uh do a disclaimer i do not uh practice
in minnesota but the judge did instruct
the jury
that they have to decide on all three
charges so they're not able to just
decide on the highest charge of
second-degree murder and then just
you know forget the other ones because
they're less included charges they must
decide on all three charges so
we're going to hear since they do have a
verdict we're going to hear what their
verdict is
on second degree murder third degree
murder
and as well as manslaughter um i say
that i don't practice in minnesota for
the very reason that in the areas that i
practice
in um once you the jury instruction
generally is once you reach the highest
charge which in this case would be
second degree murder
then you don't have to go any further
that your jury verdict sheet says you
just stopped there but that is not the
case in minnesota
so yes they have they have to reach a
verdict on all three charges and that's
what they were instructed on
so one of the main points of the defense
uh was
that george floyd had drugs in his
system and so there were other reasons
as well as derek chauvin's knee on his
neck
that caused this death so bearing that
in mind when we look at the second
degree
charge which means prosecutors had to
prove his conduct was a substantial
causal factor basically what the jury
would have had to decide
was that all the other factors weren't
key but that mainly
it was the knee on the neck would that
be correct
well what they have to let me just go
back a little bit on second degree
murder because what they have to decide
when second degree murder is that the
act that was committed by derek shoving
was a felony
that is what raises second degree murder
to the 40 years they have to show that
the assault that occurred on mr floyd
was a felony so that's really what
they're um
you know what they're looking at in
terms of in in terms of that
um in terms of that issue alone
um in terms of causation they do not
have to show
that the knee on mr floyd's neck for
nine minutes and 29 seconds was the only
cause that caused his death they just
have to show
that it was a substantial contributing
factor
so he could have had you know heart
issues and
all the other things that they were
trying to bring up the fentanyl in his
system
uh carbon monoxide from the car which
they never really you know
proved that they just kind of sort of
threw that in the mix and all the other
things that they're trying to say
those other things can exist as long as
derek chauvin's knee on his neck caused
his
loss of life that is what they have to
show and that it was a substantial
contributing factor
not that it was the only factor but it
was a substantial contributing factor um
of course derek chovin is on trial for
the killing of george floyd but
as we've been hearing this is about so
much more this is about
i guess a systemic um you know many
people believing that the police
is often too violent especially with
members of the black community
just while the trial was going on we had
the death of duante
right that was killed by a police woman
kim potter near minneapolis as well
there was the case of adam toledo
a young boy about 13 again
killed and and this on video very much
like the george floyd
killing how key is the video evidence
and now we're seeing emerge more and
more now that everyone has a mobile
phone and a camera
how key is that in this case and in
cases similar to it
well in this case the video was key but
let's not
be fooling ourselves there has been
video in other cases
and the police officer has been found
not guilty
in the case of walter scott a few years
ago mr
scott was running away from the police
in south carolina he was 27 yards away
from the police officer and he shot him
in his back and all of that was seen on
video
but at the end of the day the jury found
the jury could not reach a verdict it
was actually a hung jury
but the thing that is different in this
case and i think distinguishes it from
the other cases
is not just the video but the fact of
the matter is this was not a split
second decision because that's kind of
what
people say they can rope their heads
around is that oh it was a split second
decision you know the police they're in
fear for their lives i mean we
clearly saw from this video that uh
derek shelvin was not in fear for his
life he had his sunglasses on top of his
head
his hands and his pocket he was looking
away and he was looking like he's having
you know a walk in the bar
that is what was crucial is what was
shown on this video
not just the fact that there was video
that behind thank you so much for
sharing your expertise
with us we are of course still waiting
for the verdict and we will i hope cross
life to you
to get your reaction when that comes in
for the moment uh madam thank you very
much
uh again just to uh remind viewers who
are just tuning in
we have heard that the jury in the derek
chauvin trial for the killing
of george floyd have reached a verdict
and we are expecting
uh that uh verdict uh any time
uh soon so uh you can see there that's
the live
uh live shot of the court there
we are we were told uh we were told um
that that um would happen about 15
minutes ago or so but um i'm sure it's
imminent and we will bring you that live
here
on al jazeera we are staying with this
story
um as it develops well in the meantime
let's go to ronald sullivan
professor of law and director of the
criminal justice institute at the
harvard law school
who joins us now via skype from newton
massachusetts thank you so much uh for
being
with us um did it surprise you that the
jury
reached a verdict in what is relatively
speaking a very short period of time
it's an extraordinarily short period of
time and yes indeed it did
surprise me in a normal case a very
quick
verdict is usually a good sign for the
defense
it's usually an acquittal jurors tend to
take their time before they
convict someone and effectively put them
in jail for
years and years and years that's in the
normal case though
there's absolutely nothing normal about
this case
so it's nearly impossible to predict
what i will say though given the very
short period of time
i imagine the prosecution is very
nervous
because they too are used to quick
verdicts
meaning a an acquittal
and um we're seeing people gathering
outside the courthouse
now and we've also had even in the past
24 hours for example president
biden getting in touch with georgia
floyd's
family about the case what impact do you
think
all of that attention and the way it
obviously got very political
what do you think it will have that's
had on the trial but also on the verdict
because there
is a risk that some people will still
not see justice to be done which i
understand is obviously a difficult
concept because we don't right now know
what the verdict is
you know it was i think a bit risky for
the president to comment before
the verdict came in and the reason is
that
although the jury is sequestered that
means that they are away from everyone
and they're instructed
not to look at any media the defense is
going to argue that the president of the
united states created
an environment this is assuming there's
a conviction that the
president of the united states weighed
in and
created an environment where his client
could not get a fair
trial so personally i wish that
president biden had waited
until after there was a verdict before
commenting at all
and so i'm i'm concerned about that but
the point is the jury was sequestered
and we have to rely on the fact that the
jury
will in fact follow the instructions of
the court that they will remain
impartial that they will not
watch the news and they that they will
not allow extrajudicial
that means outside of the courtroom
influence
uh influences in any way impact their
deliberation or decision
it's very interesting i found when the
when the judge
ended the trial yesterday when he was
giving instructions to the jury he
specifically said that they must not
consider
the consequences of their verdict as
they reached it so that's what the judge
uh said yesterday but would you mind
just talking
us uh through what the charges are again
and what you think
having watched the trial for the past
three weeks will be
will have been the main sticking points
when it comes to the jury reaching a
verdict
yeah well the first charge is second
degree murder and that
is what is colloquially called felony
murder
that means if the jury finds that the
defendant
intended the felony of assault that he
intended to assault
george floyd and george floyd died which
he did
then the defendant is guilty of the
murder you don't have to prove that he
intended to
to kill him uh or intended to inflict
grave bodily harm on on him all you have
to do is prove that he intended the
assault
and if the assault uh ended in death
then the defendant is
liable so that's the top charge it
carries 40 years
uh and it is the most difficult charge
because the defense
has argued that well look there's no
evidence that he unlawfully
assaulted uh george george floyd what we
what they argue is that he was acting
consistent with the protocols of the
police
we'll see what happens there uh the
lowest count
the third count is called culpable
negligence
what that means is that there was some
duty of care owed to
mr floyd and that the former officer
did not give the care that was due to
him
was negligent didn't intend to do
anything
but just did not exercise the quantum of
care
that was due that's sufficient for
criminal neglect criminally negligent
homicide
that's count three now there's a middle
count and there's a chance that the jury
might might just compromise in the
middle
the middle count in minnesota is called
murder three or murder in the third
degree and what that means
is that the defendant consciously
disregarded
a known risk once again it's an
unintentional crime
you don't have to intend to kill anybody
but you do have to
know that there is a risk of
serious bodily injury at a minimum that
there is some risk
and you consciously disregard
that risk and that's enough for a
conviction
under count two and you know if i were a
betting person and i'm not
uh but if i were i would think that the
jury might compromise in the middle
and do a uh and convict on third degree
murder well
we should find out soon enough what
their verdict
is let's talk a little bit about
sentencing as well because obviously
that is not up to the jury that is
i think up to the judge when the jury
returns a verdict
so for example second degree murder
carries a penalty of up to 40 years in
prison when it comes to sentencing
what it's vaguely i mean obviously it's
up to the judge but what are the
differences
roughly speaking between the three
charges
so sentencing is is going to be a huge
aspect of the case
so the um the first charge the top
charge second degree murder
carries up to 40 years uh the middle
charge third degree murder
carries up to 25 years and the low count
the negligent homicide
count goes up to 10 years now that does
not mean that the court has to
give the defendant the max should he be
convicted
but it means that that is the maximum
that the court can go
so in minnesota they have a system where
the defendant can
elect for a jury to consider the
punishment
or the judge um chovin
elected the judge so if he's convicted
the judge will consider the punishment
also in minnesota there are what is
called sentencing guidelines
these are ranges that the court
should sentence within so given the
facts of this case even though the max
is 40 years
the range may be 25 to 35 depending on
what
uh another department called uh the the
pre-trial services
uh comes up with in terms of arranged
they will write
a report a pre-sentencing report about
mr chovin if he's convicted and the
judge will consider that
the judge can depart upward or downward
from
the range finally in minnesota there are
a number of
aggravating circumstances that if he is
convicted
the government the state will argue for
example
committing a grievous crime in the
presence of a minor
remember there was a nine-year-old there
that is an enhancement
so if the range was say 25 to 35 years
given a first-time
offender for homicide then that could
bump it up
even higher because it is called an
aggravating
circumstance so sentencing is going to
be important on the other end of the
spectrum
if he's convicted of criminal negligence
and the sentencing is very
low i regret to say there will be
an explosion of outrage that
minnesota has not seen before and this
is in light
of the explosion of outrage that
occurred when
george floyd was initially killed yeah
absolutely on the 25th of may uh
2020 so less than a year ago
and of course as i was mentioning with
other correspondents
this is the trial for the killing of
george floyd but we have had other cases
we had another case of a young man
killed
near minneapolis uh just last week also
a younger boy a 13 year old i believe in
chicago that was killed
if you put this in context for us
how rare is it for police officers
to who have in one way or another been
involved with the death of
especially black men how rare is it for
them to
face the kinds of charges that derek
shivan has faced
it is extraordinarily rare for police
officers to be
held to account when they have caused
the death
of anybody let alone black or brown
citizens in the united states
it is even more rare that a police
officer is convicted
of killing a black or brown person in
the united states
and that is the nature of the outrage
here
so um if you will indulge me in addition
to
uh having on my hat as a scholar and a
harvard law professor
and so forth i can also speak to you uh
as an african-american man who grew up
in the united
states it is a feeling of existential
fatigue
that you you can't drive you can't go to
the store
you can't eat skittles you can't wear a
hoodie you can't have an outstanding
parking ticket you can't have an expired
plate
without facing the death penalty
and that is a grotesque set of affairs a
grotesque
status quo that that men and women of
color
continue to experience look there are
laws about all of these things for which
these folks allegedly were stopped
none of them include the death penalty
right that's why we have a structural
divide in the united states
police officers arrest and judges and
juries fix
the punishment but what we have here it
seems
like the wild wild west with police
officers just
killing people over an alleged fake 20
bill or a packet of cigarettes that has
to stop and that's
why people are so very outraged
when these situations happen again and
again
and again so this verdict is going to
have repercussions
that extend far beyond the four corners
of that
courtroom because it is this verdict is
more
metaphor than substance it says a lot
about
what the criminal justice system is who
we take ourselves to be
as citizens of the united states and how
we
elect to respond in the face of
state-sponsored
violence may have been a little more
than you asked for but
that's my that's my two cents we really
appreciate both your expertise and your
experience uh of course and
as i said before this uh the story has
uh been headline news around the world
uh
is obviously um an issue that is of
great interest ronald sullivan for the
moment thank you and of course
we will uh get your reaction when the
verdict does come in for the moment
thank you
thank you well let's take you now
outside the court in minneapolis
where protesters have gathered let's uh
listen in because some are addressing
the crowd
and be brought back their money's not
going nowhere
the money's still there my life when
it's taken
it's not coming back george floyd
will never take another bite on this
planet again
george floyd will never take another
breath
on this planet again and until these
systems
are uprooted and recreated with
everyone's best interest in mind
we are going to stay out in these
streets we are going to continue
fighting until i feel the same justice
that this damn building fear
no justice no justice
[Applause]
get it
listen there to the protesters who have
gathered outside the courthouse
in minneapolis uh just uh if you've just
tuned in now we have been hearing
that the jury in the trial of derek
chauvin for the
killing of george floyd have reached a
verdict and we are expecting
the jury to deliver that verdict any
time now you can see
their images of the courtroom and
the now many people who've gathered
outside the courthouse really voicing
uh the anger that many have uh
shown over the killing of george floyd
and police brutality let's go to john
hendren now who has been following the
trial
for us he is outside the courthouse
as well in minneapolis uh john we were
told that we might get
the verdict about half an hour ago any
idea
if or why there's been a hold up
well barbara i imagine what is happening
is that they're waiting for all of the
major
stakeholders to show up
in a trial of this magnitude you really
want the judge the
you know the all of the appropriate
lawyers
the family the floyd family as well
those members who are allowed into the
courtroom and that has been a very
limited number
and we understand that family members
have arrived
at the courthouse we know that eric
nelson the defense lawyers arrived there
and derrick chauvin the defendant
have all arrived there a little while
ago i i was
uh giving you the wrong time because i
was basing it on east coast
time from a report i had seen well it
turns out that might be true it might
take
an extra hour for them actually to get
everybody assembled and come up with a
verdict
it's also possible that um the court is
dealing with the paperwork
that needs to be done while this verdict
is delivered although you would think
that they would have been prepared
even despite the fact that this was done
in really rapid time
less than 24 hours from the time that
the jury
began to be sequestered and isolated and
it is interesting to note that
as far as we know from the pool reports
the jurors did not ask
any questions of the court and that
seems
a little unusual because of the kovat 19
restrictions they were given
a laptop and they were allowed to
look at the exhibits that the court
had throughout this case and normally
they would go back to the courtroom to
do that but in this case because of kova
19 they did not do that and it seems
if if we have learned everything from
the pool reports that i believe we
should
that the jury really didn't need a lot
of extra information besides
what they got in the courtroom and the
speed with which they came to this
decision suggests
that they were very decisive and that
there wasn't a lot of rancor
in that room between those jurors
because after
half a day yesterday on monday and then
a little more than half a day today on
tuesday they've come down with the
decision and i expect
we will hear it soon but that the judge
wants to make sure
that everybody who is important in this
case is in that courtroom
and that he's got everything lined up
john hendren with the latest from
outside the courthouse in minneapolis uh
john you're monitoring developments
there for us but for the moment
thank you let's go to mary frances berry
who's a professor of american thought
and history at the university of
pennsylvania and also the former chair
of the u.s commission on civil rights
she joins me now
by skype from new orleans madam thank
you so much for joining
us here on al jazeera you followed the
trial
three weeks of trial you've heard the
defense and the prosecution
what is your reaction to the fact that
the jury reached the verdict and what
was it 11 hours of deliberation or so
right uh the history of these things is
that of trials is that if the jury stays
out
a lesser amount of time and this is
considered a
small amount of time and then the
verdict is likely to be guilty
we don't know if that's true i mean not
guilty uh
if they stay out uh longer then they're
qualiquing about it or whatever
and but i don't know whether history
tells us anything in this case everyone
who has spoken about this from the
president of the united states
vice president to people on down and in
people like me who have watched this
assume that sheldon will be found guilty
because the evidence seems to be
overwhelming but as we've pointed out
all you really need is one person uh on
the jury to disagree
so the idea is and if there is not
a guilty verdict in this case who knows
what will happen
if there is one it'll be great for the
legal system
for the uh idea of police being
defenders of people rather than
folks who go around injuring you when
you call upon them to help
it could change the whole game of the
way police
behave towards citizens if in fact he is
acquitted even after
all of this evidence that has come in
all the videos
endless experts and all the rest of it
it would just mean that we're in deeper
trouble
and we have to figure out something to
do about reforming the system
so everyone and most people are hoping
that in fact
there will be a guilty verdict at least
on some of the counts that are before
the jury
and let's just remind the viewers that
that chauvin
has been charged with three different
counts second degree murder third degree
murder and then second degree
manslaughter yeah the lesser charge that
i think carries up to 10 years
uh in prison i mean you mentioned him
getting acquitted but do you think that
many people would be disappointed if for
example he's found guilty but only of
the second degree manslaughter charge
i think people who have watched this and
who saw
what happened and who've seen the videos
and who've been involved and engaged in
it will be
very disappointed because they could see
with their own eyes
that in fact he killed a guy he murdered
him
and he's a police officer so they will
be disappointed i think that it is less
likely that there will be concerted uh
protest activity over a period of time
if he is indeed convicted of something
but if he is convicted of nothing then
you've got a different problem on your
hands
i'm sure you've seen the images that are
sort of coming out now from outside the
courthouse protesters have gathered
there they've been gathering there
more and more as the news came in that
the verdict that the jury had reached
the verdict
do you worry about unrest both in
minneapolis and across the united states
uh there is a great concern that there
will be
uh act a protest activity i would be
happy if there's protest activity
and he is acquitted because people
should protest
such a thing i don't think people mean
when they say protest
violent protest that's not what the
people who are articulating this mean
but they are taken
to mean that primarily by people who
like to distort what they're saying
it would be surprising to have him
acquitted and have no one protest and
everyone go home
silently mary francis berry forgive me
for interrupting you but the judges just
come back so we will cross after you
again
but let's now take you to minneapolis
the courthouse
where judge peter cahill has started
all right please be seated
of the jury i understand you have a
verdict
members of the jury i will now read the
verdicts as they will appear in the
permanent records of the fourth judicial
district
state of minnesota county of hennepin
district court
fourth judicial district state of
minnesota plaintiff versus derrick
michael chauvin defendant
verdict count one court file number 27
cr2012646 we the jury in the above
entitled matter has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021 at 1 44 p.m
signed juror for person juror number 19.
same caption verdict count two we the
during the above entitled matter as to
count two
third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 45 pm signed by jury four person
juror number 19 same caption
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter as to count
three second degree manslaughter
culpable negligence creating an
unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april 2021
at 1 45 pm jury four person zero
one nine members of the jury i'm now
going to ask you individually if these
are your true and correct verdicts
please respond yes or no juror number
two are these your true and correct
verdicts
yes juror number nine are these your
true and correct verdicts
yes juror number 19 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 27 are these your true
yes you're number 44
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes juror number 52
yes juror number 55
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes
juror number 79 are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
juror number 85 are these your true and
juror number 89 is this your are these
your true and correct verdicts
yes jury number 91 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 92 are these your true
yes are these your verdicts will say you
won so say you all
yes yes members of the jury i find that
uh the verdict says read reflect the
will of the jury and will be filed
accordingly
i have to thank you on behalf of the
people of the state of minnesota for not
only jury service
but heavy duty jury service what i'm
going to ask you to do now is
to follow the deputy back into your
usual room and i will join you in a few
minutes to answer questions
and to advise you further so all rise
for the jury
all right be seated
[Music]
with the guilty verdicts returned we're
gonna have uh
blakely you may file a
written argument as to blakely factors
within one week
the court will issue findings on the
blakely factors the factual findings
one week after that we'll order psi
immediately
returnable in four weeks and we will
also have a briefing on after you get
the psi
six weeks from now and then eight weeks
from now we will have sentencing
we'll get you the exact dates uh
in a scheduling order is there a motion
on behalf of the state
move to have the court uh revoke the
defendant's bail and remain him into
custody
a pending bail is revoked bond is
discharged and the defendant is remanded
to the custody of the hennepin county
sheriff
anything further all right thank you
we're turned
and that was derek shoving being led out
of the court in
handcuffs and remanded in custody after
he was found guilty
on all three charges relating
to the killing of george floyd so guilty
of
second degree murder guilty of third
degree murder and guilty of
second degree manslaughter just to give
you an idea the second degree murder on
its own